في الداخل الاوكراني معركه عسكريه ضد عدو
من الخارج واخرى ضد عدو داخليه متمثل
بالفساد تخوضها اوكرانيا الان حيث عاد ملف
الفساد ليطفوا من جديد بعدما نفذت السلطات
الاوكرانيه اليوم سلسله مداهمات وعمليات
امنيه لمكافحه الفساد اطلق عليها معركه ضد
العدو الداخلي اطلقتها بالتوازي مع اقالات
واستقالات سابقه لكبار مسؤولين اوكرانيا
وبحسب المعلومات فان العمليات استهدفت
مسؤولين كبار في وزارات الدفاع ومكتب
الضرائب الاوكرانيه فيما علقت مهام اداره
الجمارك اضافه لكل من الملياردير
الاوكراني ايغور كولوموسكي ووزير الداخليه
السابق ارسين وقالت رئيس الاجهزه الامنيه
وقال رئيس الاجهزه الامنيه الاوكرانيه انه
وفقا لاوامر رئيس زيلينسكي فهذه ليست الا
مرحله اولى ولن يتوقف عند هذا الحد بل
ستشمل اي شخص يخون بلاده مهما كان المنصب
فيما علق مسؤولون اوكرانيون على هذه
الحمله بانها ضروريه كي لا تنقطع
المساعدات الغربيه الكلاب سواء كانت
عسكريه او ماليه او اغاثيه
[موسيقى]